I need you to trust me so that was a
piles of dead Nazis body crushing
transformers and enough Williams to make
even Dolores jealous
yes Westworld episode 6 is here with a
ton of new information and we're gonna
break it all down and answer who maven
serac have resurrected where Caleb and
Dolores are headed and just how pissed
Charlotte is gonna be hint it's a lot so
get ready to take a deep dive because
here we go we begin with maven a
simulation of the sublime the place she
wants to be more than anywhere else
since that's where her daughter was
stored at the end of season two it's not
real whoever generated by serac as a
reminder of what she's fighting for we
last saw Maeve killed by Musashi Deloris
her body is in the process of being
recreated but she tells serac she's
gonna need some help we'll learn that
three host bodies are being prepared for
her to help but we'll get into who those
three are in a bit
Maeve wakes up back in war world she's
basically killing time and Nazis until
her body is ready now whoever decided to
invite William to group therapy well
that's mistake number one he says
there's no God and that humanity is just
a thin layer of bacteria in a ball of
murder hurtling through the void he
really should be a poet he has such
disdain for humanity here that it's
quite the shift when he later says this
I'm gonna save the [ __ ] world anymore
one on one therapy session the therapist
Natascha says William is the only one
who has the key to his own experiences
he has to come to terms of the fact that
he killed his own daughter
that's why I don't belong here blowing
up playing box natasha is assigning him
to a our therapy short for augmented
reality therapy the same therapy it
seems Caleb received from his flashback
last episode Natasha says this type of
therapy is great for those suffering
from PTSD so it's likely Caleb received
it from the trauma he experienced as a
soldier natasha receives her insight
profile so we know this scene takes
place slightly after dolores released
them all to the world and it's not good
she's predicted to lose her medical
license in one to two years than her
kids and they even know she's had
affairs with multiple patients if you
look at the bottom here you can see
she's restricted to treating only class
Hue patients which also happens to be
the same class caleb is this seems to be
the hopeless class where nothing can be
done this is likely why she is given
William as a patient will later see
Natasha hang herself a result of losing
her husband and kids
Williams blood is taken as the staff
discuss how they're short-staffed since
anarchy and chaos wreak havoc on the
outside world
an unknown protein is detected in his
blood which will later find is used to
track William this is what Charlotte
pricked him with at the end of episode 4
bullying was also given a drip just like
the one Caleb and most members of
society have this allows the staff to
give him a calming limbic drug like the
one Jerry used way back in episode 1 we
get a glimpse of the completely
out-of-control Rehoboam circle here like
the one serac had on his watch last
episode it's picking up a divergence in
San Francisco that divergence Charlotte
she's picking up Nathan as we get
glimpses of anarchy in the streets
including this dude drawing graffiti of
the maze which was a huge motif in
season 1 we can see Charlotte's scratch
her wrist which is a nod to how she
feels uncomfortable in her body that she
wants out a few episodes ago Dolores had
to patch her up because she kept clawing
at herself Charlotte will get her wish
of getting out of her skin this episode
it's just that it will all be burned off
she tells Jake to keep Nathan safe while
she finishes up some things at work
notice here more circle symbolism in the
background he's decided not to read
their profile saying I
know what the future holds for us but I
do know that it's not up to a machine to
decide oh you poor thing
romped until Charlotte they have the
votes ready to stop surak's takeover of
Dell O's but he's quickly taken out by
Sir ax men this allows Iraq to continue
on with the takeover Charlotte calls
Dolores and tells her she's failed but
Dolores isn't done with her she needs
her to gather the host data from dell
o--'s before serac destroys it Charlotte
expresses her concern over the safety of
her family but Dolores stops her how
will this later affect her allegiance to
Dolores will is tied up for his first AR
therapy session a young boy which will
later find out is a young version of him
leads him into his childhood bedroom
which is ironically adorned with western
posters young William is reading a book
called sir Rowan in the Lady of salon
which isn't an actual book perhaps this
memory isn't what it seems
Charlotte arrives at Delos and is joined
by serac he wants the entire place
locked down the hosts assets destroyed
and for every employee to be tested
since he has a hunch one of them is a
Dolores mole meanwhile Maeve has taken
down an entire platoon of Nazis and is
reunited with Lise Sizemore over drinks
the background glitches for a moment and
she senses she's been moved her body has
begun the reconstruction process and
soon she'll be reunited with some
friends it doesn't take long for the
dello sign to switch to insight we see
sir axe watch turn back to normal as it
seems the world is back on track and
stabilizing to his plan he wants every
host destroyed in the data wiped even
though that's trillions of dollars down
the drain the only thing he wants is
Dolores encryption key meanwhile
Charlotte backs up the hosts data to an
external device when she's caught she
does the old snappy snappy because
snitches get stitches will is brought to
his therapy session by this guy who you
might remember as hosts major Craddock
in season two our first hint at what's
happening here is actually taking place
in augmented reality here he meets
multiple versions of himself family will
Men in Black Will Young will and child
will there's also James Telos because
even in death your father-in-law has to
bust your balls back in war world may
have reunites with Hector and is able to
restore his dad
he's one of the three bodies along with
Maeve that is being reconstructed in her
office Charlotte is able to see that
these reconstructions are happening note
the statue in the Mack round here all by
itself looking very similar to the
statue of these two women holding hands
a few episodes earlier this is a subtle
hint that production designers are using
to show that Charlotte is becoming her
own person it also makes sense
considering the title of this episode is
decoherence which comes from the
scientific term quantum decoherence it
states that if a quantum system isn't
kept in isolation it will break down
over time so okay mister tedtalk what
does that mean for Westworld well
Delores and her copies are like one of
these systems and the more they aren't
kept together the more they diverge
slowly breaking down becoming decoherent
Charlotte sees that will is in Sonora
Mexico by tracing that protein she
injected into his blood she tells
Dolores this which is likely where her
and Caleb are headed to next episode
either that or Berlin where that final
mystery host of Dolores is more
importantly Charlotte learns of the
three other hosts that are being created
alongside me we know that one is Hector
the one that Charlotte later crushes in
our hand and by looking at the host ID
number and cross-referencing it with
earlier seasons one of the others is
Clementine Pennyfeather the actress was
also at the west-world season 3 premiere
now we don't know who the other ideas
but there was another season 2 character
who was invited to that premiere who was
also an ally of Maeve's
so my speculation is that it's Tao
Okamoto scare achter ha Daario from
season two's Shogun world it also
appears that Connells pearl was
recovered by serac so that Maeve could
use it to interrogate Dolores wills
therapy from hell continues and he
basically tries to figure out if the
park made him violent or if he was born
that way
we learned that child will was so
sadistic his father even said what's
wrong with you after he broke a fellow
students arm and knocked out his teeth
the park in essence became an outlet for
will to unleash this violence Delos
Assam if this life happened to him or if
he chose it which William responds if
you can't tell which is the same line
that is told to young William upon
entering the park way back in season 1
episode 2 charlotte pretty much knowing
her time
up takes out a gun and this canister a
canister which will later be used to gas
her fellow board members at the meeting
we see Charlotte take off this gold
wristband which suggests her
metaphorically taking off the chains of
her own enslavement making her own
choices but actress Tessa Thompson said
it was just so that they could keep good
continuity during the upcoming fight
scenes sera conforms the group he knows
who the mole is
Charlotte he's been watching her ever
since he landed with the other members
being gassed serac does what he does
best in these situations in Holograms
the [ __ ] out Maeve continues her
interrogation of Dolores wanting to know
if her daughter is safe Dolores won't
give up that info easily let alone the
encryption key to someone who is aligned
with the man who wants to kill their
kind Maeve senses Charlotte in the host
creation room where Hector's purl is
subsequently taken out and crushed
something Maeve doesn't take very well
now before Charlotte can crush Mavis
pearl she's stopped by a gang of sir axe
goons but not before grabbing Connells
pearl which has Dolores's copy in it
effectively shutting her off from the
simulation Maeve is in Charlotte is
later surrounded and were told serac
wants her alive but she's able to
activate one of the riot control BOTS to
come to her rescue now we did learn back
in that episode that they ordered 300 of
them so we'll be interesting to see if
they come into play in later episodes
Williams therapy seems to be going well
as he's killed all the other Williams
the only one that remains the man in
white and I finally understand my
purpose
I'm the good guy will is taken out of
the AR by Bernard and Stubbs
it seems the doctors forgot about him
during the chaos
Bernard Stubbs and William all want to
stop Dolores but it was Dolores who put
William there and also a copy of Dolores
Connells who informed Bernard where
William was so it seems like Dolores
plan involves Bernard and William
teaming up even though it looks like it
may be counterproductive to her overall
goal Maeve awakens after being
constructed to see one of her fellow
hosts coming out of that white goo as
stated earlier this is likely Clementine
orhan REO in the final scene Charlotte
gives Nathan an elephant an animal that
she said in Episode three is extinct
just like Nathan will be in a few
minutes
her car is blown to pieces by Sir axe
men and she comes crawling out like some
Terminator the final shot is of a single
tear rolling down her face as she
watches her family burn Charlotte's
world has been upended her reason of
being gone this will make her a wild
card in the next few episodes perhaps
she will be the anomaly that agitator
who serac said will destroy all of
mankind we'll just have to wait and find
out thanks for watching everyone please
make sure to LIKE and subscribe and
leave your thoughts and theories in the
comments below you can also follow me on
Twitter at things story whitey until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much